hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video but today we're gonna be talking
about some monster on our world and in
specific we're gonna be talking about
how to mount mom mounting at Monster
Hunter rolls a very good technique
especially if you use it correctly it
isn't very effective in a teamfight
and it's also good in solo but it's
definitely way more useful in a
teamfight but regardless let's get
started so start off not every monster
Monster on a world is the same they all
have different resistances different
types of damage and also resistances to
mounting as well it also depends on
where you hit them I know for a fact in
the nerd ghonte and I'm pretty sure I
butchered that name I apologize but I
know for a fact that hitting that
monster in the tail and not hitting it
from its side will cause it to mount so
if you hit it in the tail you can mount
it but on the side toward the leg you
cannot mount it sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't it doesn't really
make sense to me and it's super odd why
it does this but I do know for a fact
that the tail does work there are two
parts that I like to talk about in the
mounting phase and it's the jump attack
in the rodeo phase for the jump attack
phase it's super simple find a decently
elevated position like a rock and jump
and swing at the monster right when you
make contact and you should hopefully
enter the rodeo phase if done correctly
during the rodeo phase this monster will
try to knock you off pay attention to
the prompts at the very top of the
screen and follow them follow what they
say sometimes the monster will shake you
and you have to brace for an impact or
you have to move to a different part of
its body because he's trying to crash
into a wall seat so he can knock you off
once he stops doing that span the [ __ ]
out of that triangle button and stabbed
him repeatedly you're only gonna be
doing one damage but after eventually
you'll receive a prompt to do a special
move like firing a gun or a slash of
swings depending on what weapon you use
you can knock the monster over make sure
to pick a spot on the monster that's
week four preferably like the head to
maximize the amount of damage that you
do once that happens it's up to you if
you're playing solo or you and the team
if you're playing in a group to get as
much damage as possible while the
monster is knocked over use all of your
special combos or hide damaged bullets
and shoot at his weak points which is
usually marked by scars and scratches
once again depending on the monster that
you're fighting quick side note for
people wondering you can mount the
monster if you have a gun and certain
weapons like the feathered blade and the
hammer have certain attacks that have
you suspended in the air for a little
bit and those can also cause you to mob
the monster as well I hope you guys
found this helpful some people on the
forum seem to be a little bit confused
about it so I thought I'd make a video
just in case others
like I said mocking is a super good
technique to use in monster on a world
that can knock the monster over for that
tons of damage break its body parts and
reveal scratches and stuff like that so
it's super useful even in solo because
it gives you that a little bit of a
breather
so either way like the video if you guys
did enjoy if you're new then consider
subscribing and also hitting the bar on
X date so you never miss one of my
videos I'm gonna start posting more
Monster Hunter World content once the
full game has been released since it
isn't a beta and with that guys hope we
have a great rest your day
and peace out